You have zero control over the ocean.
The only thing that you have control over
is your attitude and your actions.
In the United States, current rate is 22
veterans kill themselves every 24 hours.
I went to Iraq, and I came back
a completely different person.
You start thinking
about the firefights you've been in,
the dead bodies you've seen.
Excuse me.
I've been on just about
every drug on the market.
I figured I'd be okay with dying.
Surfing, that was the biggest thing
on my bucket list.
I was gonna go surfing, go home,
and commit suicide.
When I caught that wave,
it wasn't death and destruction and hell.
The ocean is the one place
I can go to for peace.
I started Operation Surf
to take a group of veterans surfing.
It became clear to me what my purpose was.
It's rough, okay?
-Don't give up.
-No.
Surfing is medicine.
It helps them describe themselves
with a new story.
It not only changed my life,
but it saved my life.